knight into b4 then go g5 and suddenly  f6 is coming in and that can be really  dangerous for white for black  yeah so maybe h6 no he takes knight b4  anyway i mean he has to take  and maybe we might be seeing this we  might be he's it's on the board and did  you see that yeah  that is it  blunder rook d8 duke ba5 luke d8 blunder  mate checkmate  no way to defend against the mate  and that's it  that's a cold shower that is a cold  shower i mean i don't know what was the  right move after g5 but rook b5 loses on  the spot  yeah well after you mentioned that you  want to follow up f5 with g5 yeah that's  it liam designs it's a total shock  maybe he should have played the move h6  just to to create some loops stopping g5  but okay magnus would probably then it's  only a very very unpleasant position